[Música]
hola con todos mi nombre es mauricio
fernandini tengo 52 años y ante la
pregunta recurrente y tú a qué te
dedicas yo nunca sé qué contestar
tengo lamento decepcionarlos una severa
crisis de identidad y de esa adaptación
soy una persona profundamente es
adaptada a todos los sistemas y a todos
los estereotipos y la sociedad puede
haber creado sobre las personas y sobre
los profesionales
me pregunto si soy periodista a veces me
paran en la calle me dicen que el
invento programa 20 lucas eres un chef
nou a ver qué receta me puedes dar no
también me paran en la calle y me dicen
tienes una academia marinera que bonito
baila quiero mandar a mi hija donde
queda tu academia
tú no eres el campeón nacional de
marinera
entonces la verdad es que yo nunca me he
detenido a reflexionar salvo en este
momento quería poner en la ficha
registral cuando uno lee ocupación no
porque actualmente estoy desempleado soy
un orgulloso desempleado y un orgulloso
de esta adaptado
deshabitado desde que tengo uso de razón
mi infancia transcurre acá soy
chiclayano el colegio acá pasaba los
veranos en pimentel
me dedicaba a la contemplación de todo y
no me adaptaba vuelvo al tema a nada no
jugaba fútbol con los compañeros tampoco
jugaban las muñecas con la chica
tampoco enganchaba con los juegos de
trenes ni de carritos tampoco era una
persona que no quisiera ir al colegio en
fin mis papás sufrían muchísimo conmigo
no sabían si llevarme al psicólogo al
chamán creo que hicieron ambas cosas y
seguía siendo un niño que no era viable
de manejar que era lo que yo hacía
genuinamente bailar como un poseso por
todas las habitaciones de la casa
inventar de historias que hasta ahora yo
mismo me sorprendo como podría haber
sido tan persuasivo no
a mi hermano mayor por ejemplo mayor que
yo tres años me vestía con un pantalón
negro lo recuerdo nítidamente una camisa
blanca una corbata michi y le decía que
venía del teatro de 2 de mayo de dar un
concierto y que la gente me había
aplaudido y mi hermano los ojos redondos
la boca abierta y me decía por qué no me
ha llevado el concierto no tú no estás
preparado para escucharme entonces era
de verdad creo que un niño inventivo no
diría mitómano no sino que creo que sus
deseos los trasladaban la realidad y los
contaba como tal entre las cosas
inventivas y los bailes que creaba dónde
pero sabía a todos los primos mayores
para que hagan la coreografía y de
verdad los lograba disfrazar les ponía
camisas toallas sábanas y ejecutaban
coreografías por toda la casa mis padres
estaban desconcertados y moss entonces
optaron por algo
que este los agradezco hasta el día de
hoy
vas a ir a clases de marinera norteña y
vamos a tratar de ver cómo reaccionas
ante estos estímulos porque ya nos
cansamos de matricularse en todas las
clases o ver finalmente qué te hace
feliz y terminas inventando siempre un
juego nuevo no
y es así como empecé a bailar marinera a
los 5 años de edad en la foto que estoy
compartiendo con ustedes tengo 7 y estoy
bailando con blanca carmona carmona con
quien decidimos ir a muchos concursos
locales
a pesar de las adaptaciones de mi
infancia tengo una vida estructurada que
termine el colegio fui a la universidad
de piura y empecé a trabajar en
televisión
creo que aprendí el lenguaje televisivo
que sigue siendo un desafío porque está
mutando todo el tiempo y ahora la tele
compite con las redes sociales y la
televisión no tiene un lenguaje propio
la televisión es como un vampiro absorbe
un poco del cine un poco en la
literatura un poco en la fotografía un
poco de la prensa escrita y crea un
lenguaje no en este transcurrir de los
años yo ya había tratado de crear un
propio lenguaje televisivo
volvemos a lo mismo que no encajaba con
lo que mis jefes querían y ahí había una
continua desadaptación porque escribiste
así y no de esta manera porque vas tras
esta primicia y no tras esta otra hasta
que encontré a este personaje
en un relleno sanitario su nombre es
alfredo con lan
y el reportaje era sobre relleno
sanitario sobre reciclaje pero él vivía
en medio del relleno sanitario y la
primera impresión es que era un una
persona que había perdido el juicio un
desequilibrado que se yo empezó el
diálogo y me di cuenta que era un hombre
culto con un lenguaje articulado y dueño
de una gran espiritualidad y género que
yo me replanteé mi vida completa
completa
como ven bueno era un tipo que no tenían
pudiera ver su apariencia recuerdo que
le faltaban varios dientes y entre las
primeras cosas que me dijo fue que amaba
la música clásica llamaba a leer y que
lo que había conquistado era su libertad
en el relleno sanitario no tenía jefes
el creado a su propio horario tenía una
radio a pilas la golpeaba se activaba en
sol y armonía y escuchaba música clásica
como yo he sido un niño inventivo y una
persona que también a veces me da con la
mitomanía
le hice una re pregunta para saber si lo
que me estaba contando era más o menos
verificable o no bueno y que tenores te
gusta
y él me respondió
mario lanza camusso y este gordito
gordito italiano barbón como se llama
bávaro
el reportaje se hizo se grabó y lo que
fue confrontar a la audiencia de los
años 90 tan dominada por el consumismo a
un hombre que no tenía nada no tenía
casa no tenía carrera no tenía auto no
tenía aspiraciones no tenía metas no
tenía objetivos que tenía una felicidad
envidiable transmitía ser un hombre
realizado insisto dueño de una
espiritualidad sobrenatural quizás así
sean los ángeles me imagino que no
enganchan en nada de lo mundano
confrontado el reportaje que mi jefe de
ese entonces no se animaba a emitir no
la reacción fue impresionante
y esto obligó de alguna manera a
replantearnos varias cosas en la
televisión de ese entonces
estaba de alguna manera dominando el
sensacionalismo las crónicas policiales
el morbo lo primario porque hacían
muchisimo rating esta historia no tenía
nada de sensacionalismo al contrario
escapaba a todo acto consumista de los
90 era más bien reflexionar tú qué estás
haciendo con tu vida eres realmente
feliz por lo que estás haciendo porque
este hombre no tiene nada y la pasa
genial no
él sentía que estas pampas de san
bartolo llenas de rellenos sanitarios
eran como sus dominios como que me
recibía realmente un rey en sus dominios
absolutos
para suerte mía avaro te llevo a limar
un concierto y yo le enseñé el reportaje
favor o ti se conmovió que su admirador
vive en un relleno sanitario y nos
invitó al concierto que dio en el
hipódromo
fuimos me costó mucho trabajo del estilo
de esta manera porque él decía que el
agua lo abruma va el agua me abruma
mejor no me vas a bañar o sea déjame así
como estoy leo nombres que no sea
invitado pavarotti no o sea no no
estamos así de extras no ser los
protagonistas fuimos
gracias a él conocí a pavarotti no
y este reportaje finalmente obtuvo un
premio de la unesco tuvo obtuve una
calificación importante la medalla de
oro del mejor reportero joven del mundo
de ese entonces pero yo no soy muy
confiado de los premios y de las
condecoraciones y de las medallas de los
títulos y de todo lo que la sociedad va
creando para que nos quedemos
enganchados en una vanidad que no quiero
cultivar desde esa perspectiva lo que yo
quiero siempre es reflexionar en torno a
las cosas que nos pasan entonces dónde
están las verdaderas historias o sea
dónde están las verdaderas lecciones
donde un periodista puede encontrar una
primicia que lo puede llevar a obtener
un reconocimiento que va más allá del
perú no estaba en palacio gobierno
probablemente también haya de primicias
pero las noticias y las cosas que en
realidad uno a veces no está buscando
son las que más nos sorprenden
tenía todo para triunfar en la
televisión para tener una carrera
exitosa en la televisión y sin embargo
desistía a ello no porque existía ello
porque no les voy a contar la historia
ya se la saben en los 90 los titulares
se evitaban desde el cine había una
dictadura tú no podías hacer periodismo
densidad que tenías que decir y eso a mí
me castró completamente me anuló me hizo
sentir una profunda frustración
y a pesar que tenía el lenguaje
televisivo aprendido no me sentía como
haciendo periodismo porque no era la
búsqueda de ninguna verdad no
no sé si la palabra correcta es me
refugié decidí emprender otro camino
porque hay otra de esa adaptación al
periodismo de ese entonces que no era
real y yo no me que me sentía y adaptado
que hice me inventé un programa
gastronómico que se llama a fuego lento
que fue del 2003 al 2006 para suerte mía
terminé grabando en muchos países de
europa con los cocineros más consagrados
los primeras tres despedidas michelín y
no se había generado ahí la revolución
gastronómica peruana ni el estado había
apostado por posicionar la gastronomía
no esté en el mundo yo seguí mi instinto
de infancia y celebro que en nuestra
cultura me refiero a la chiclayana los
que vivimos acá todo gira en torno a la
mesa
hemos escuchado hace poco nuestro amigo
chef y si queremos expresar nuestro
afecto es a través de la comida no si
vamos a bautizar a alguien
postergamos que no vamos a poner sino
que vamos a invitar
y si nos queremos avistar con alguien le
vamos a preparar específicamente algo
entonces yo crecí en esa cultura donde
mi padre me ayudaba al mercado modelo
los domingos recorríamos el mercado y
todo giraba en torno a la comida la
comida es una forma de vivir en realidad
de una forma de decirle a la otra
persona tantas cosas entonces no es que
me refugié en el programa de gastronomía
sino es que yo tenía esta profunda
atracción hacia la cocina desde
probablemente generaciones anteriores y
quería realizarme estudiar cocina poner
un restaurante
por ahí no iba mucho la salida no me
inventé este programa astronómico a
fuego lento grave en muchos países del
mundo y me formé como un periodista
gastronómico
cuando ya creía que iba a empezar mi
carrera como periodista gastronómico el
canal donde se emitía a fuego lento me
dice no queremos programar sin actuar
les es muy bonito tu programa qué lindo
parís y limitarla cliente españa pero no
no va más queremos solamente noticias de
actualidad ningún género en actual y
literalmente enfrente una situación de
desempleado como muchos de ustedes me
han pasado en la vida
entonces cuando la gente piensa que el
éxito te cae el cielo
asumen que tener un formato televisivo
que llame la atención es éxito para mí
en realidad ha sido la lucha constante
de muchas de esas adaptaciones
posicionar los formatos que he
compartido con algunos de ustedes y que
logrado tener al aire
es como que la crisis siempre nos tiene
que llevar a un escenario mejor la
adversidad siempre resulta estimulante
el desempleo no hay que verlo de una
manera
aterradora ni desalentadora el desempleo
puede ser el estímulo para crear cosas
nuevas porque a cerrarnos a fórmulas que
la sociedad nos impone termina la
universidad se practicante y el gerente
general o en tu propia compañía se
asesora nos hace feliz me quedé
reflexionando siempre en torno a raíz de
las cenizas ha sido ya media el
reportaje que he compartido con ustedes
donde él de manera no se innata emana de
esta felicidad de esta realización y
encontró un equilibrio entre un trabajo
que tenía era dignísimo porque no le
faltaba el respeto a nadie me sentaba
contra nadie y lo que le gustaba hacer
y ese es el tema de alguna manera en el
que quiero reflexionar siempre inclusive
hasta el día de hoy debo de admitir que
hay en mí una suerte de adolescente que
le gustaría someterse a un test
ocasional para ver qué va a ser
consumido en los próximos años
pero me siento muy seguro si soy un
periodista un chef un periodista
gastronómico o una persona que cultiva
apasionadamente la marineta quiero ser
absolutamente honesto con ustedes yo no
siento que haya encontrado
así la pasión de las pasiones yo lo que
siento es que me he sentido desadaptado
muchas veces en mi vida y no me he
querido quedar en la frustración en la
amargura en la crítica a terceros sino
seguir explorando hasta encontrar un
código que me guste o un escenario que
me apasione más que la anterior pero
nunca me he quedado desde niño
entrampado
no sé en la nada que creo que es letal
para cualquier persona
el tema de seguir explorando seguir
buscando no tener ningún pudor de no
encajar en esta fórmula que la sociedad
nos impone con los 35 años que
tuve en el banco de la nación y lo
celebro si la persona fue feliz con esos
35 años en el banco bien por ella cada
uno tiene que explorar su ruta su mundo
y cuando ese mundo se cae como es el que
me ha pasado sistemáticamente a mí que
cuando iba a hacer la carrera televisiva
la dictadura toma la televisión y para
mí eso no era así cuando ya tenía el
programa gastronómico con todos los
méritos del mundo el canal decidió hacer
en actuales y cuando intentó volver a
hacer el programa 20 lucas que es el
último que tuve ninguno lo que hizo lo
presenté a todos los canales y todos me
quiero no va a funcionar esto no sirve
estás equivocado es para que los saques
en otro país
hasta que finalmente el programa empezó
tímidamente en tvperú
y de verdad que fue un éxito no no no sé
cómo explicar qué es el éxito en este
caso no a mí me gustaba y a una
audiencia le gustaba y se generó un
binomio feliz porque yo no tenía que
hacer ninguna concesión negativa a qué
me refiero que muchas veces en
televisión por el rating y por el éxito
terminas haciendo cosas dónde y potestas
a tu forma de vida no haber hacer rating
este
no sé el morón exacerbado torturar a tu
mamá la tortura la más más que está
subiendo el rating y eso es éxito para
muchas personas no tengo tantos puntos
de red de venta altas personas pero en
base a que entonces nunca logré transar
con hipotecar mi forma de ver la vida
con mis contenidos televisivos
20 lucas era finalmente una crónica
urbana donde yo entraba a los mercados
que son extraordinarios no porque son
espacios teatrales donde hay una puesta
en escena de miles de personas libres
dispuestas a ganarse la vida
considero que de una manera artística
porque se detienen a observar gracias a
tu reflexión los puestos están hechos
pero escenográficamente los disfrutan
los de pescados nada más este pico que
un mercado entonces meterte con una
cámara un mercado y prenderla y
solamente escuchar todo lo que la casera
te puede decir para que generen la
compra ya era divertidísimo realmente
divertido y si realmente uno quiere
conocer el alma de un lugar de una
localidad tiene que traer un mercado
porque es lo que refleja el espíritu de
esa comunidad
es así como se realizó a 20 lucas y es
así como yo mismo se re 20 lucas después
de 10 años porque sentía que estaba en
una rutina aprendida y que no quería
quedarme el resto de mi vida haciendo
algo que ustedes consideraban exitosos y
se los agradezco pero para mí era un
lenguaje aprendido y quería asumir
nuevos retos volví de alguna manera
a reflexionar y me daba cuenta que esto
que era mi afición de niño y que yo
practicaba apasionadamente ya había
tomado mucho espacio mi vida yo estaba
grabando 20 lucas me llamaba ebay o
demencia o bien tenemos museo en la
noche bailas conmigo y dejaba todo lo
que estaba haciendo en mi grado en algo
nueva york
hoy hay una gira nueva york a california
en esto que vengas a hablar conmigo y yo
iba y empecé a ganar dinero bailando
marinera y tenía ya entre 48 y 47 años y
es como que plantearte una carrera de
bailarín a los 48 años era como que otra
desadaptación la asumía o no la asumía
no y honestamente no voy a dejar de
bailar hasta que el cuerpo
me ve bailar y boleros probablemente no
pero es lo que me hace genuinamente
feliz bailar que considero indispensable
en la vida encontrar una atmósfera un
espacio que lo hagamos
por eso por amor no por un sueldo no por
meritocracia no por ser aprobados por
los demás no por ser adaptados a lo que
todo el mundo hace sino porque
genuinamente es lo que nos provoca si a
mí genuinamente me provocó ir a
concursar a los 40 años de edad al
concurso nacional de marinera in sufrir
tantas es adaptaciones en el sentido de
cómo basar la densidad qué papel no lo
vas a hacer mal no nos tiene que
importar nunca el tema si contamos con
la aprobación o no o la desaprobación de
los demás no
yo honestamente cuando me pregunten y tú
varón a qué te dedicas como verán no sé
qué contestar
voy a retomar probablemente mi carrera
periodística pero quiero compartir con
ustedes algo que es absolutamente
honesto
soy un feliz desadaptado en el camino de
la vida se ha propuesto ser feliz y me
importa si esto es aprobado o
desadaptado soy amor soy pasión soy
consecuente y soy determinado muchas
gracias por su tiempo
[Aplausos]